Greenhouse systems are the
types of food production systems
to grow crops under
controlled environments using
natural sunlight in
two-dimensional space.
When it comes to
vertical farming,
these are the types of
controlled environment
agriculture systems using either
container-based applications
or, in warehouses, to
use artificial lighting,
such as fluorescent
light or LED lighting,
to grow the crops in
hydroponic systems
or aquaponic systems in
three-dimensional space.
We are trying to design
environmental control
around the plant and actually
use the plants as sensors.
We are really looking into
applications of precision ag
or digital agriculture
applications
as we look at future for more
sustainable plant production
systems.
My ambition, my goal,
is to-- in the future
to have plans, actually,
to be able to control
their environments and make
adjustments to their production
settings and systems.
This will be the
most sustainable and
resource-conserving
way of production
in the controlled environment
agriculture systems.